nos dicen a continuación se muestran las
gráficas de ft que por cierto es igual
al logaritmo natural de t cuadrada y hd
tm que es igual al valor absoluto de 3 t
menos 2 todo esto hemos dado al producto
ya esto le quitamos 3 arrastra las
variables para mostrar que ecuaciones
deben de satisfacer puede haber
cualquier número de variables en una
categoría y algunas variables pueden no
estar en ninguna categoría y ahora date
cuenta que aquí tenemos a la gráfica de
estas dos funciones aquí tengo a efe dt
que bueno habíamos dicho que f dt es el
logaritmo natural de t cuadrada y aquí
tengo ht que es igual al valor absoluto
de 3 t menos 2 todo esto menos 3 ok y
ahora date cuenta que aquí aquí tenemos
a cada una de las variables y tenemos
algunas expresiones que queremos ver si
cumplen o satisfacen estas estas
variables que tengo aquí por ejemplo si
yo que si a arrastrar este uno a esta
categoría estaría diciendo que cuando yo
sustituyó el valor de tf1 justo aquí es
decir que si tuviera el valor
de 3 de 12 todo eso menos 3 igual al
lugar y natural de tf1 elevado al
cuadrado si se cumple esta igualdad
entonces estaría en lo correcto al
arrastrar esta variable a esta categoría
de igual manera se opusiera por ejemplo
aquí allí uno estaría diciendo que
cuando yo sustituyó en lugar de th 1 es
decir me quedaría 3 veces llevo 1 - 2
todo eso en valor absoluto menos 3 igual
a logaritmo natural de 1 elevado al
cuadrado si se cumple esto entonces es
que yo no debería de estar en esta
categoría y bueno justo tras eso vamos
pero como no es muy fácil rayar aquí la
página de khan academy entonces lo voy a
poner justo aquí déjame bajar por acá
voy a buscar mi pizarrón y ya lo tengo
aquí en el pizarrón dice ft efe dt es
esta gráfica de verde que por cierto
vamos a ponerlo de una vez con verde
efe dt es la gráfica de verde esta de
kim y htc es la gráfica de azul así que
con el mismo color con un color azul
esta es http y bueno si te diste cuenta
la primera categoría hablábamos de
buscar para qué valores dt se cumplía
que esta función era igual a esta
función vamos a escribirlo para que
valores de t el logaritmo natural de t
cuadrada de t cuadrada esto es
exactamente igual a el valor absoluto y
déjame ponerlo con este color el valor
absoluto de tres veces este de tres
veces de menos dos todo esto todo esto
menos tres y si te das cuenta resolver
esta ecuación que tengo aquí no está
nada sencilla sin embargo es muy
importante que sepamos a qué me refiero
cuando pongo esta igualdad de aquí lo
que quiere decir es que estoy buscando
para que test se cumple y esto es
importantísimo para que te esté cumple
que ft que ft porque ft es justo esta
función de aquí sea exactamente igual o
déjame cambiarlo cuando sea exactamente
igual que http lo que buscamos es para
que valores de tema
esta igualdad y bueno dos gráficas son
iguales para un cierto valor de tema si
se cumple que toman un mismo valor para
alguien cuando ambas tienen un mismo
valor para ti estoy buscando que estas
dos funciones sean iguales eso quiere
decir que cuando yo lo busque aquí en
esta gráfica voy a buscar dos puntos
para los cuales estas dos funciones son
iguales o dicho de otra manera estas dos
funciones se intersectan y si te das
cuenta estas dos funciones
efe dt y htx está de azul se intersectan
en dos puntos este este es el primero de
ellos este de aquí el cual dice que te
subíndice 5 el valor que tómate justo
aquí voy a ponerlo aquí a este de aquí
este de aquí este subíndice 5 ok
cuando te vale te subíndice 5 james bien
toma este valor que es el valor del
subíndice 5 y vale 10 subíndice 5 ahora
bien quiero que te des cuenta de algo
el valor de t subíndice 5 para t se
cumple que estamos en este punto equipo
y en este punto x si te das cuenta
estamos en un punto de intersección de
las dos gráficas eso quiere decir que
cuando yo sustituyó y déjame ponerlo así
cuando yo sustituyó a t por el valor de
t subíndice 5 es decir que f dt
subíndice 5
dt subíndice 5 cumplen que esto es
exactamente igual exactamente igual que
el valor que toma la gráfica h h
pero evaluada en el mismo punto en el
punto del subíndice 5 o espera déjenme
cambiar de color en el punto de
subíndice 5 estamos en el mismo valor
que por cierto ambos valores sabemos que
equivalen a su índice 5 a esta de aquí
esto es lo mismo que 10 subíndice 5
estos dos son iguales y bueno pues esto
también me da y es un buen índice 5
es el mismo valor que tomamos para ello
las dos gráficas aquí valen lo mismo
valen 10 subíndice 5 cuando te vale de
subíndice 5 o dicho de otra manera ya
tenemos un valor para ten un valor para
t que podemos sustituir justo aquí para
el cual se cumple esta igualdad
curiosidad de su 26 5 me quedaría que el
logaritmo natural de t subíndice 5 al
cuadrado es exactamente igual que es
usted lo que yo quería que tres veces
este subíndice 5 menos 2
todo esto en valor absoluto menos 3 ok
entonces ya tengo uno de los valores
este subíndice 5 cuando te toma el valor
de t subíndice 5 se cumple esta igualdad
ok y existirá otro bueno claro que si el
otro que existe es justo este de aquí
este de aquí esté aquí es el punto en
donde se intersectan también la gráfica
de ft con la gráfica de hdt es decir que
cuando t cuando te déjame ponerlo así
vamos a subir cuando te vale t subíndice
2 estamos aquí
sub 26 2 james vale 10 subíndice 2 que
es este valor de aquí 10 subíndice 2 y
eso quiere decir que f efe de 3
subíndice 2 es exactamente lo mismo y lo
estamos corroborando justo aquí la
gráfica es el punto de intersección que
h de este subíndice 2 que por cierto
esto es lo mismo que el valor que toman
que es el subíndice de 210 subíndice 2
sé que suena un poco confuso con todos
los subíndices pero aquí lo importante
que quiero que veas es que estamos
encontrando otro valor para t para el
cual se cumpla esta igualdad que tengo
aquí es decir que ft es igual a http que
valor a bueno cuando te toman el valor
de t subíndice 2 cuando te toma este
valor de subíndice 2 estamos en este
punto de aquí y es el punto donde se
intersectan ambas gráficas y por lo
tanto
efe dt subíndice 2 es igual a hdt
subíndice 2 que es justo lo que querían
por lo tanto antes de que se nos olvide
este subíndice 5 t subíndice 2 vamos
justo aquí en donde estábamos trabajando
con la página ok entonces arrastremos a
t subíndice 2 a esta categoría y vamos a
arrastrar también t subíndice 5 a esta
categoría y ojo recuerda que acá arriba
vamos a subir un poco la pantalla dice
puede haber cualquier número de
variables en una categoría y algunas
variables pueden no estar en ninguna
categoría ok de hecho si nosotros vemos
10 subíndice 2 y 10 subíndice 5 estos no
están en esta categoría definitivamente
son los valores respectivos que toma
esta función y que es lo mismo que esta
función pero no son los valores de t que
hagan que se cumpla esta igualdad ok
ahora fijémonos en la siguiente
categoría dice 3 t menos 2 en valor
absoluto menos 3 es igual a cero es
decir htc igual a 0 vamos a revisar nos
el pizarrón para poder trabajarlo
estamos por acá ok y ahora lo que quiero
es que a déjenme cambiar de color lo que
quiero es que hdt no voy a poner justo
aquí que hd tm
sea igual a 0 sea igual a cero o dicho
otra manera lo que estoy pidiendo es que
el valor absoluto de tres veces esté
menos 2 ok todo esto menos 3 sea igual a
0 y existe algún punto donde se cumpla
esto bueno si te das cuenta y si lo
pensamos un poquito el punto en donde se
cumple esto es aquel punto en donde ya
vale 0 lo que estoy buscando es que hdt
se haga 0 es decir que nos subamos y
bajemos en el eje de las 10 y bueno si
no subimos y bajamos en el eje de las 10
estamos parados sobre el eje x y existe
un punto aquí existe este punto de aquí
en donde la función hdt no sube ni baja
y de hecho de esta parte creo que es el
único punto que nos ponen el punto t
subíndice 4,10 subíndice 4 o dicho de
otra manera
sabemos que es pero es que aquí necesito
este color que ye subíndice 4 es igual a
cero es decir nos subimos y bajamos
cuando
cuando sustituimos atm por de subíndice
4 es decir que aquí estamos parados en
el subíndice 4 cuando te vale t
subíndice 4 se cumple esto y vamos a
ponerlo esto pasa cuando evaluamos en la
función h de subíndice 4 de lujo y por
lo tanto ya tenemos el valor que
nosotros queremos de subíndice 4 de
subíndice 4 hace que se cumpla esta
igualdad que tres veces este subíndice 4
- 2
todo eso en valor absoluto y ya eso le
quitamos 3 sea igual a 0 y de hecho si
te das cuenta es el único valor de hdt
que se ve en esta parte de la gráfica
que cumple esa propiedad es el único
valor que intersecta al eje de las 'tres
fíjate que este valor de aquí intersecta
al eje de las 10 pero bueno ese sería
otro caso entonces vamos a arrastrar el
valor de t subíndice 4 en nuestra a
nuestro navegador de internet para que
no se nos olvide entonces éste
perfecto y ahora lo que queremos es que
el logaritmo natural de t elevado al
cuadrado sea igual a cero es decir
efe dt es igual a cero y regresemos de
nuevo a nuestro a nuestro pizarrón
electrónico que tengo aquí ok y ahora lo
que quiero y déjame escribirlo justo
aquí ahora lo que quiero es que el
logaritmo natural en lugares pero déjame
cambiar a un color más verdoso este el
logaritmo natural de t cuadrada sea
igual a 0 y lo que estoy buscando es una
t que cumpla esto o dicho de otra manera
lo que estoy buscando es que ft ft sea
igual a 0 y si te das cuenta con un
razonamiento muy análogo lo que estamos
buscando es una cierta bien para ft de
tal manera que no subamos le bajemos y
la única que cumple es justo esta de
aquí cuando te toma el valor de t
subíndice 3
aquí estamos entre subíndice 3 ok jett 3
vale 0 nos subimos y bajamos es decir
que esto es igual a 7
de 30 porque nos subimos y bajamos o
dicho de otra manera esto se cumple esto
se cumple cuando sustituimos el valor de
t por t subíndice 3 es decir el
logaritmo natural del subíndice 3
elevado al cuadrado es 0 o dicho de otra
manera
efe de este subíndice 3 esto es igual a
por lo tanto con el mismo razonamiento
podemos concluir que la única que cumple
en esta parte que podemos ver de
nuestras dos funciones que es igual a 0
es cuando te vale de subíndice 3 esta
sería mi tercera respuesta cuando te
vale t subíndice 3 cruzamos al eje de
las 3 y si te das cuenta es el único
valor que hace eso por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo voy a ponerlo por acá voy a
escribirle a mi navegador
vamos a arrastrar o esperar que pasó
voy a arrastrar el valor de t subíndice
3 ok a esta categoría
y creo que ya tenemos todo y además
recuerda que nos decían que existen
algunas variables que no están en
ninguna categoría ahora lo último que
quiero que veas es que aquí me falta
poner por ejemplo ate subíndice 1 pero
te subíndice un no representa el valor
que tomamos cuando interceptamos al eje
de las 10 cuando la función hdt
intersecta al eje las yes y bueno no
eran ninguna de estas tres categorías
que me pedían por lo tanto es hora de
comprobar respuesta y de lujo estamos
bien nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo